Born and raised in Texas, Jeb
Bush moved to Florida in 1980.
The son a  nd brother of presidents.
He himself was governor of the
Sunshine State from 1999
to 2007, where
he quickly became known as a
champion of school choice and fiscal
responsibility.
In 2016, he had an unsuccessful
run for president, and he now
resides in Miami-Dade County,
happily retired from
political life, a self-proclaimed
old school conservative with
libertarian blood running through
his veins.
I talked to Bush in October for a
special issue of reason
devoted to all things Florida.
He told me the reasons he believes
more people are moving to Florida
than any other state.
What he thinks of current Governor
Ron DeSantis and leading Republican
presidential candidate Donald Trump.
His problems and they are many
with President Joe Biden.
And what's so special about
immigration and America?
Governor Jeb Bush, thanks for
talking to Reason.
Honored to be with you, Nick.
So let's start with
the question of, you know, Florida
has become the fastest
growing state in the country.
What explains Florida's growth
as a destination for people
wanting to move there and live there
and work there?
I think Florida works pretty good.
It's like whatever problems we have
pale by comparison to two other
states. And I mean like you, no
disrespect to the Northeast, but if
you have business up there like
I do and you go and you drive
like you're going to get a broken
back, basically trying to go
from here to there because the
infrastructure is
decayed, the challenges
are immense. And you come here and
the roads, the roads are working.
They've got a lot of people on them,
but fewer potholes.
Things work better.
And so it's for people
that come to visit.
They can kind of get the allure
of Florida. And then typically what
happens is they visit a few times
and then they say, all right, I'm
making the.
When making the jump.
When did you move there?
What year?
1980.
And Florida has at least since
the I mean, in the postwar era, but
definitely in the 60s, 70s,
80s, 90s and continuing
just saw really kind of explosive
growth.
Texas has also where you
grew up. You went to school at
University of Texas Austin.
Yeah.
I hope that they lose in
whatever, you know football games
that they have coming up this
season. I'm rooting for Ohio State.
Be that as it may.
Both Texas and Florida,
two states that have become reliably
red, are now kind of kicking
the butt of New York and California.
These four states are the four most
populous states in the country.
Is there something going on
where the general kind
of political
system in Florida
and Texas is being
revealed as better than
the ones that are in place in
California, in New York.
In Miami Dade County, where I live,
has 2.5 million people.
It's a big urban, teeming
place full of
diversity.
It has a 1.4%
unemployment rate.
I mean, effectively, it used to be,
Nick, we're old enough to remember
full employment was like at 4%.
Oh, yeah. So, I mean, people are
half the people have two jobs, I
guess. I don't know. It's like it's
it's full of opportunities.
The tax code matters, obviously,
for people with
more wealth and for sure.
We don't have income tax.
We have smaller governments.
The impulse isn't to later try to
tax your way to prosperity or
regulate your way to prosperity.
It's not a perfect place for sure.
I get nervous about bragging too
much because the minute you
stop challenging
basic assumptions about the role of
government is you're after
few sets in and government
kind of just starts filling the
seams.
And so we've
had a great run because we've had a
period of limited government
and we don't try to
micromanage people's lives.
And as long as we do that and we
stay focused on the important
long term things, and I would say
makes it making sure our
infrastructure stays up with the
growth, making sure our natural
systems are protected, which is an
important conservative principle
in my mind is, you know, we could
rape and pillage the the
the swamplands around South Florida
and you would have a hell of a
problem going forward.
So investing in these long term
things, which they don't do in
California and New York because
they've made 20, 30 years
ago, they make obligations
to the unions and obligations
in the here and now, that that
creates a government that is far
bigger than it is in Texas or
in Florida.
Talk a bit more about conservation
efforts or the environment in
Florida is a big deal
because, you know, it's a state that
is surrounded by water.
You know, three sides, right.